what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
washington's trying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get our lunch money
right
today was a hell of a day i'm exhausted
7 p.m but we were not going to forget to
do this
i'm here with the sailor or the prisoner
i can't decide yet
but don't forget that lunch money it's
not sponsored by block five block five
has three products you can buy and sell
crypto you can earn
up to eight point six percent apy in an
interest bearing account or you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
oh wow it went up sorry go on
go get a block five account bonfire.com
what's
up well wait by the way
do you see this promo right here pomp
boys motors everyone go check it out pop
boys motors that's my dad's spot go
check that out
little mechanic if you're in north
carolina definitely check it out yeah
roanoke rapids go ahead go go get some
business i'll charge him later for this
promotion
go ahead so so earlier today
as we were escaping the cold winds of
new york city
i hear a scream and
it is because bitcoin i was on the beach
i was on a flight and it popped over 20k
and you boy was
20k for the first time ever
and now i just checked the price it's at
one thousand three hundred and four
dollars and sixty cents that's a whole
hundred dollars that went up
since our flight to here what is our
guy's name who
uh there was a father today who reached
out to us do you remember his name
no i think it was like a username why
don't you look real no i think it's
okay okay she's gonna look real quick
but basically the story goes
i'm sure that there's a kid there's a
young man uh who is watching this
today his father who we will tell you
his name in a second woke him up
and when he woke him up he said guess
what
bitcoin's over 20k and his young son got
really excited and he said son what do
you think
pomp's gonna say on lunch money today
and you know what his son said
his son's the smartest viewer we have
his son said that pomp's gonna say
i told you so chris sterzinger
so chris sturgeon zinger and his son
already knew what i was gonna say today
so your son is a genius
because guess what i told you also i
told you this was going to happen
all we're watching is exactly what is
supposed to happen you have a fix supply
asset
demand is going through the roof you
literally have
wild madness going on in the markets you
have the cio
of guggenheim scott leonard is literally
on
uh television today saying that they
believe bitcoin's true value right now
is thousand dollars
give me a break let's go i told you give
me
a break all right are you ready yes
u.s retail sales decline further as
covid in a lack of additional fiscal
stimulus way u.s retail sales fell
for a second straight month in november
falling one point
i'm reading 1.1 last
month i i wrote about this i told you
all this was gonna happen
i called it the dead cat bounce dead cat
bounce
remember how he didn't like that phrase
yes i it happened in china and i told
you it was gonna happen here
was basically it the sales fell all
economic activity fell drastically
then it started to come back as they
opened and it looked like there was this
massive surge we're going back we're
going back and going back
and then what ends up happening is in
china they only got to twenty percent of
pre
uh uh eighty percent of pre-pandemic
levels so it's still a twenty percent
drop
and so that's what's happening here is
we're never going to get back to that in
a short period of time now maybe over a
really long number of years we can get
back to those levels
it's not going to happen what you have
is you're still shutting down businesses
you're still shutting down restaurants
you're still telling people to sit in
their homes you're telling them it's
illegal to walk outside
la mayor loser and you're literally
starting to
uh and you're not giving people money
they don't have money to spend
they're not allowed outside duh of
course sales aren't going up
you guys wanted to rant here's a rant
all right ready mackenzie scott
announced on tuesday her second major
charitable contribution of the year
giving away nearly 4.2 billion
to 384 organizations as part of a plan
to donate a majority of her fortune
i am all about this mackenzie scott
about a donate also a gazillion now
kenzie scott does not speak to the press
there has not been a proper profile a
proper
interview with her if anybody finds one
send it my way but she is super private
does not speak to anybody you know in
the public eye keeps a low profile and
bam hits you with 4.2 billion dollars
donation so here's what's crazy is
mackenzie scott's giving one
uh uh 5.9 billion dollars
to 500 organizations so what what is
that on average
oh what oh am i supposed to know that
500 million this is where i'd be five
hundred thousand
th this is where i don't teach you this
is where i don't teach you how to fit uh
i don't fish four years
no grab your calculator go to your
calculator
go to your calculator in your eyes go to
your calculator he doesn't know
okay wait till she wait till she finds
out that you should take the zeros off
no i know that that is what you do no i
know but you said
oh you said 5 billion to 500. but how
many how many
no it's 5.9 i my guess is that actually
if you put the numbers together at 6
billion
that she gave to five i don't even know
how many zeros go into okay
we'll just move on next
mathematical genius either
i don't put together a pivot table for
you
why do you need excel all i do is i deal
with bitcoin okay
uh yeah i i can add up satoshi's real
fast satoshi's
yeah come on bolt a european competitor
to ride hailing giant uber said it had
raised 150 million euros or 182 million
dollars
to bolster the safety of its platform
through facial recognition
or and ai bol is actually really popular
in europe
and i am actually really glad to see
another european um
european uh unicorn they don't have
enough over there
i'm all about the european startups i
just did a profile dossier on daniel eck
of spotify
and you're drinking my water and um and
he built spotify in a time where
everybody was in
if you weren't in silicon valley like
you weren't getting funding
sorry for my rant next
what do you think about this i like bolt
ride hailing it's the future
um spotify
got a big boost this year from an
unexpected audience do you want to guess
which one children
nope what gamers
so as the streaming platform looks back
on its biggest trends of 2020 one thing
is certain
people are playing lots of video games
in 2020.
people streamed music from their gaming
consoles 55
more this year compared to last year
that's wild
i mean if you think about it people want
to listen to music they're sitting at
home of course all this stuff's going to
be up
so i did a deep dive go to
theprofile.sac.com to read my dossier on
daniel eck who's the ceo and founder of
um spotify what's one thing you learned
from him he don't take meetings before
like
noon he only has like three he only
takes three meetings a day
and he walks around hangs out with his
kids his family
before he goes to the office and doesn't
start meetings until noon and takes
three meetings a day
all right it's lunch money time
oh damn i thought i was gonna be like
one of those young kids on uh we're
taking your toy away
anthony uh
he did that while i just did a panel
come on on video
let's go
i'm thinking i'm taking it away i'm
literally taking it away
matthew ring ganu why do many people
tout
bitcoin as the greatest wealth
redistribution mechanism i swear to god
of our generation when it seems that the
already wealthy individuals in our
society are better positioned to be the
primary beneficiaries of
massive price appreciation it's because
the plebes the everyday people they got
in before
the institutions they got in before all
these wealthy
suckers so most of the people are just
it's just available to anybody right
like normally
in a startup investment uh you got to be
rich you got to be an accredited
investor to be able to invest in the
private markets and then
and then like the everyday person only
gets to invest once it's public in the
public markets but all the value or a
lot of the value is being created sure
there's a value gets
created afterwards but like it's way
better to be an early investor than a
later investor in those companies
this is in this really weird situation
where it was literally public from day
one anyone with an internet connection
could have went and got this thing
um you could have mined it you could
have bought it like you could have done
a lot of stuff
uh and most of the institutions they're
coming in now they're buying twenty
thousand bitcoin
twenty thousand dollar bitcoin warren
buffett he's gonna be buying two hundred
fifty thousand
bitcoin you at home hopefully you were
buying
less than twenty thousand dollar bitcoin
and the institutions are buying it
from you
uh brent kt hey what's up okay
what big things do the pump slash pimp
team have in store for 2021
individually and as a lunch money team
stay tuned to find out is a lame answer
okay so individually i personally have
many goals
guys what do i do with this child i got
it
okay so individually um the profile in
january is gonna be publishing a lot of
uh stuff a lot of
q a's with um really interesting people
uh there will be an olympic athlete
um she's amazing there will be an
entrepreneur that you probably know
yeah and there's somebody else okay
oh sorry uh i think we should do merch
if you all want me to do merch
wait individually or as a team oh you
weren't invited you had your time let me
have my time i think that we should do
merch i feel like if we do merch
then all of a sudden people would wear
it if you would wear merchandise would
you wear
my get money get paid sweatshirt
i would get one leave a comment if you
wear some merch maybe that's what we'll
do maybe that's the 2021
next that's it oh that's it all right
see ya
[Music]
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends